well it's barely spring and the hint of
warmer days kind of given me the itch to
get outside and plant something maybe
you too
but is it too early the fickle warm cold
warm weather has also planted the seed
of doubt about what will survive if we
start planting our gardens now so i went
to the expert dr q at star nursery
the nursery was buzzing with wannabe
gardeners like me looking for the
perfect flowers veggies and herbs to
plant now and hopefully sustain the
change of seasons unexpected freezes
and the wind of course i want something
that's going to hold up a little bit and
the weather has been so
on again off again as you know that i
don't want to get something that's going
to last a day most plants can take
extremely high temperatures and
extremely low temperatures as long as
it's just for a short time so good news
dr q is giving us the green light to
start our spring gardens but he also
warns to stay alert to sneaky cold snaps
it is safe to plant but if
if you're forecasting some really cold
weather like freezing temperatures we
recommend that you protect all the young
plants with
some kind of a frost protection like
these little hot caps that you can put
over brand new planted little little
plants that are in the ground that will
protect them from the cold larger plants
he says may need covering with fabric
like this material called insulate or
breathable burlap works great too so
which plants are best for planting right
now so you should be pretty safe for
planting any of the of the warm season
vegetables and herbs and also any of the
warm season flowers are good to put in
right now as well dr q says patio pots
raised boxes or flower beds are all good
growing containers but prepping the soil
with good organic matter matters a lot
and our filthy rich gold here actually
has our starter fertilizer in it so it
has fertilizer that will keep your
plants healthy for up to six months
after you plant them but to get a good
bumper crop of veggies dr q recommends
adding fertilizer every six to eight
weeks during the growing season
star nursery has all of the planting
mixes and fertilizers you need to help
your beautiful garden grow and flourish
we could always use a little help with
that unless you're an expert i'm
certainly not i always need some help
coming up this week dr q will show us
more tips and let us know if old man
winter has killed off some of those
perennial flowers and other plants that
you may have in your yard and flower
beds also we'll share the best timing of
when to move plants bushes and maybe
some trees around your yard if you're in
the mood to rearrange because you can't
do it just any old time of year they get
a little fickle about when they like to
be messed with
good information though i mean with so
many people who are new to our valley i
remember when i first moved here years
ago and it was like when can i plant
because other cities you're not supposed
to plant before
mother's day
you wait that long it's a little oh yeah
mother's day it's too late yeah it's a
small window
well i did dr q asked me he said you
know do you see any more freezes coming
and i said no we can always get that
little last cold blast right around the
beginning of april but not a free not a
hard freeze not for the valley anymore
so that's what those adorable little
hats are for yes
if we get a chilly night you can put one
of those little hats on and cover them
up but
i think we're out of the woods for
freezes so that's good news